c'est l'heure à présent de votre
rendez-vous du lundi rencontre avec un
sénateur aujourd'hui nous partons dans
le Loiré cher avec la sénatrice uduc
Jacqueline gourau un département vous
allez le voir durement frappé par les
inondations début juin près d'un mois
après les habitants et les commerçants
sinistrés ont encore du mal à reprendre
le cours normal de leur vie c'est un
reportage de samchir à la faire t
saincir Jacqueline gourau sénatrice du
loirécher vice-présidente du Sénat nous
sommes ici à la Ferté saint-s en Sologne
et nous allons rendre visite à une
commune qui a subi de grosses
inondations récemment et qui était qui a
été une des communes les plus touchées
du Loir etcher bonjour
Jacquine bonjour comment tu vas et toi
ça va mieux mais il y a encore beaucoup
de travail à faire Jean-Paul prince est
le maire de La Ferté saint-ire une ville
traversée par le Cosson ses eau sont
redevenues paisibles mais début juin la
rivière est montée jusqu'au pont tout
est allé très vite même le capitaine des
pompiers s'est laissé surprendre dans
les garages on a eu allez on a eu 1,50
1,60 d'eau dans les garages d'accord et
puis après dans la maison B voyez on
voit bien sur les sur les vitres vous
voyez à peu près à la hauteur où c'est
monté c'est monté à cette hauteur là
voyez en gros 1,35 1,40 à l'intérieur de
la maison à l'intérieur tout le mobilier
est perdu les murs sont imprénés d'eau
c'est très émouvant
de
voir au fond les dégâts que l'eau fait
dans les maisons comment les maisons
sont
totalement dévastées ça permet de
toucher du doigt je dirais la réalité et
et les problèmes que cela pose à tout à
chacun bon courage sur les 600 maisons
de la ville 120 ont été inondés grâce à
la solidarité les sinistrés ont pu être
provisoirement relog mais la plupart des
commerces gardent porte closeasy l'état
de catastrophe naturelle a été décrété
mais la propriétaire de cette pizzerria
ne se fait pas d'illusion sur les
indemnités qu'elle touchera la
catastrophe naturelle nous aide pas
forcément parce que la franchise elle
est colossale ça représente 10 % des
dommages parce que il y a catastrophe
naturelle parce qu'il y a catastrophe
Natur y avait pas eu catastrophe
naturelle la franchise était moins
élevée c'était une franchise fixe pour
dégâts des EOS ce qui m
bien sûr en premier lieu c'est le
problème des assurances les témoignages
qui vous disent que l'état de
catastrophe
naturelle finalement ne facilite pas
toujours les indemnisations mais au
contraire pour les affaires par exemple
de
franchise va les va rendre les
franchises plus élevées c'est une chose
que je que je ne savais pas qui m'étonne
à quelques pas de là la boulangerie
est-elle aussi fermée dégâ a ce chiffre
à 300000 € là voyez ben le four le four
lui il a subi ah oui en effet même
schéma à la boucherie voisine où toutes
les machines sont perdues impossible de
rouvrir boutique avant plusieurs
semaines le manque à gagner est énorme
on a plus du tout de ressources
donc actuellement on attend on attend
les experts savoir comment ça va se
dérouler et on on n sait pas plus ça
fait quasiment un mois que le sinistre
est arrivé mais pour l'instant rien ne
rien ne bouge j'ai beaucoup réfléchi en
faisant cette visite avec vous sur le
fait que j'allais notamment pour les
commerçants écrire au président de
région que je connais bien François
bonau pour lui dire bah alors
concrètement comment on fait vous êtes
responsable de la politique économique
maintenant depuis la loi notte comment
on fait pour aider ces familles de
commerçants qui n'ont plus de ressources
pour la mairie aussi la facture
s'annonce salée au moins 200000 € de
travaux qu'elle n'a pas les moyens de
payer le gouvernement a annoncé une aide
exceptionnelle au collectivité mais
personne ne sait encore de combien sera
l'enveloppe Jacqueline Gouro bonjour
sénatrice udi UC du Loir etcher merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation on l'a
vu hein cette situation encore
dramatique dans cette commune de La
Ferté saint-cire après les fondation
vient le temps et bien des questions et
des indemnisations est-ce que les
départements finalement sinistrés ont
été indemnisés à la hauteur de la
catastrophe selon vous c'està-dire que
c'est un peu compliqué parce que pour
l'instant rien n'arrive alors on a
entendu parler d'aide de l'état des
départements des régions voire des
municipalités des intercommunalités mais
on ne sait pas très bien comment cela
s'emboî d'ailleurs je l'avais prévu si
je puis dire puisque avec
l'expérience j'avais posé au ministre de
l'intérieur cette question dans une
question d'actualité récemment en disant
mais comment tout ça va-t-il se
coordonner et je sens pour l'instant que
les assurances prennent en CH les mains
en pardon prennent les choses en main
mais avec des nécessités
d'expertise de temps d'asséchement dans
les bâtiments et ça ne va pas vite et
comme vous l'avez vu il y a des couples
de commerçants qui sont bien sûr qui ont
perdu leur outil de travail mais qui en
plus sont sans ressources puisque ils ne
travaillent plus ils ne peuvent plus
travailler donc il y a une solidarité
qui doit se faire et ce que je vais
après cette visite je dois dire que je
vais essayer à nouveau de demander une
coordination entre tous ceux qui peuvent
venir aider les sinistrés on vous a
entendu aussi dire et bien que vous
alliez interpeller le président de de
région comment fait-on en tant que
sénatrice pour faire avancer les choses
et accélérer le processus
d'indemnisation de remboursement de ces
commerçants d'abord quand on est
impliqué dans un territoire le premier
vice-président de la Région est le maire
de Blois que je connais bien puisque je
siège avec lui à l'agglomération
blaisoise je vais l'interpeller
directement lui disant écoutez Marc
comment fait-on maintenant pour répondre
immédiatement à ces sinistrés je dois
préciser aussi une chose c'est que les
maires jouent un rôle absolument
important ils ont joué un rôle important
pendant l'inondation parce qu'ils
étaient là sur le terrain et que eux
aussi vont essayer de faire accélérer
les choses par exemple le maire de La
Ferté saint-cy organise une réunion le 8
juillet avec tous les acteurs politiques
et les sinistrés pour essayer de faire
avancer les choses ouais comment on on
est arrivé à cette situation est-ce
qu'il y a une une défaillance en matière
de prévention de ces inondations selon
vous c'est un peu surprenant parce que
on est dans une région bien sûr c'est la
Loire le fleuve important mais la Loire
n'a pas débordé ce sont des rivières
secondaires voir des tout petits
ruisseaux qui qui ont débordé alors
certains pensent que ça n'est pas
suffisamment entretenu et cetera alors
aujourd'hui vous savez que les mairies
et les intercommunalités n'ont pas la
compétence gestion de l'eau et
prévention des inondations puisque c'est
encore euh ça ça n'est pas encore
appliqué puisque c'est la loi gmapille
qui enfin la loi maptam qui a voté gmapi
et qui va transférer en 2018 cette
compétence là il y a bien sûr un une
réalité c'est qu'il a plu beaucoup
pendant 3 jours sans interruption avec
des pluies très très très fortes sur des
sols qui étaient déjà engorgé d'eau
puisqu'il avait plus les semaines
précédentes d'autre part moi je crois
qu'il y a un phénomène très particulier
dans notre département c'est le
phénomène forêt vous savez que la forêt
bien sûr dans un premier temps sert
d'éponges c'est-à-dire est un réceptacle
des EAU mais quand elle-même est saturée
si je puis dire et bien la forêt relâche
toute l'humidité et je crois que ça en
Sologne
accentuer les crues ou mais il y a pas
problème d'entretien des forêts
notamment non c'est des forêts qui sont
des forêts soit domaniales soit privées
qui sont d'une manière générale très
bien entretenu je crois qu'il y a il
faut le reconnaître parfois des
phénomènes climatiques des phénomènes
naturels qui euh qui prennent le pas sur
l'homme même si la prévention est
toujours nécessaire et par exemple moi
j'ai mis sur pied lorsque j'étais
présidentE de l'agglomération
c'est-à-dire en 2001 euh j'ai lancé un
programme qui a été parfois très mal
compris euh sur le Blaisois mais quand
on voit ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on
est heureux de l'avoir fait mes
successeurs l'ont poursuivi c'est ce
qu'on appelle le déversoir de la
bouillie figurez-vous que dans un
déversoir qui est fait pour accueillir
l'eau quand il y a des inondation et
bien au cours des siècles enfin du
siècle dernier euh c'est construit 150
maisons comme ça on sait pas très bien
comment avec des gens de voyage qui se
sont sédentarisés d'autres populations
et nous avons mené euh un grand projet
avec le plan Loire grandeur nature de
Michel Barnier où nous avons au fur et à
mesure des cessions des maisons nous
avons racheté les maisons pour qu'il n'y
ait plus
d'habitants dans cet endroit et je crois
que ça a été une très bonne idée parce
que aujourd'hui ce déversoir nous a été
utile dans les crues du beuverron et du
Cosson qui sont les rivières concernées
par ce que nous venons de voir à la
télévision chacqueline Gour je voudrais
et vous entendre sur la loi de travail
on sait que le Sénat a terminé l'examen
des articles et des amendements vendredi
après 2 semaines est-ce que le texte qui
a été modifié par la Haute Assemblée
vous convient oui il me convient
globalement même si c'est toujours
perfecti on pu dire qu'il était
peut-être trop libéral pour les
centristes euh nous avons eu je ne peux
pas le cacher de grandes discussions sur
l'affaire des 35 heur alors quand on
voit je dirais ce qui est dit sur les
ondes nationales on dit que c'est la
suppression des 35hur ça n'est pas tout
à fait cela hein il s'agit de dire que
il y a des accords d'entreprise et que
s'il n'y a pas d'accord d'entreprise on
peut aller au-delà des 35h c'est-à-dire
jusqu'au 39h mais globalement
globalement je crois qu'il y a eu un
très bon travail de fait nous avons eu
d'excellents rapporteurs et globalement
je crois que le
groupe votera le texte je dis bien le
texte du Sénat parce que c'est toujours
difficile à faire comprendre par les
citoyens quand on nous voit voter la loi
travail ou la loi et le comerie les gens
se disent tiens c'est bizarre mais il
faut expliquer bien sûr que c'est un
texte modifié par le Sénat on a pu dire
aussi que ce texte servait finalement de
laboratoire en cas d'alternance en 2017
sur les propositions économiques est-ce
que ce sont aussi les propositions
décentristes moi je vais vous dire je
suis tout à fait prudente par rapport à
cette pensée ou ces déclarations je
pense qu'on est un loin du scrutin
présidentiel de il y a l'étape des
primaires qui concerne bien sûr les
républiains ici au
Sénat que la
situation économique politique et
sociale évolue vite qu'il y a des
événements que nous ne maîtrisons pas
comme ce qui vient de se passer avec le
brexit je pense que les laboratoires je
crois que on a des grandes lignes on a
des grandes idées nous les défendront au
moment des présidentiells mais ça n'est
pas l'heure des programmes présidentiels
ici au Sénat ouais justement vous en
parlez vous êtes proche de François
baayrou qui soutient Alain Jupé si Alain
Jupé n'est pas le candidat de la
primaire de droite le soir du 27
novembre est-ce que François baayrou
devra se présenter pour qu'il y ait une
candidature du centre en tout cas lui a
toujours dit que si les électeurs les
citoyens n'avaient comme choix sur la
table qu'un choix entre Nicolas Sarkozy
François Hollande et Marine Le Pen que à
ce moment-là il ferait ce qu'il faut je
crois que c'est suffisamment clair ouais
même si on sait que les sondages sont
assez et bien mauvais pour lui entre 9
et 12 % en ce moment ah ben moi je
trouve pas ça mauvais du tout ça prouve
qu'il y a une famille politique
centriste en France qu'elle soit à 12 %
aujourd'hui comme base parce que on a
même vu des sondages où il était lui
François Baillou à 14 il y a une chose
qui est certaine si il y a un candidat
centriste je suis sûre que ce doit être
François baillerou parce que il porte
cette famille centriste il porte cette
idée cette famille centriste continue
d'exister grâce à lui et après une
campagne on peut imaginer que le score
ce sera sera encore beaucoup plus haut
merci beaucoup Jacqueline gourau d'avoir
répondu à mes questions c'est l'heure de
la rubrique Alex refait le
portrait
bonjour Alex bonjourine vous allez bien
très bien merci bon moi ça va aussi
madame Gouro bonjour bonjour je suis
content de vous voir on on va commencer
cette chronique en parlant de politique
comment êtes-vous arrivé en politique
j'ai cru comprendre que c'était un peu
par hasard c'est en allant à la formacie
vous avez rencontré la belle sœur de
Valérie giscardesttin l'histoire
commence comme ça pour la campagne
présidentielle de
1974 c'est vrai qui me demande de
m'occuper de la campagne de valer Régis
cardestin dans le Loir cher mais ça
serait c'est ce qu'on appelle le
conjoncturel il y a du structurel quand
même derrière bon la conclusion c'est
heureusement que vous n'avez pas croisé
la belle sœur de Jimmy Hendrix ça aurait
pu être plus rock remarque oui ben on
sait jamais vous avez toutes vos
question et bonne à prendre alors la
politique c'est bien mais l'histoire géo
c'est encore mieux vous allez même
devenir professeur d'histoire géo et
vous en avez gardé des séquelles parfois
lorsque vous présidez la séance au Sénat
en tant que vice-présidente j'ai
l'impression de revoir la professeur
d'histoire géo vous faites peur à tous
les élèves regardez qui est
pour qui est contre et bien on va faire
un assis debout pour la fin ah ben c'est
comme ça hein on peut pas faire
autrement parce que un d'écart moi je
fais un assis debout alors qui est pour
bon bah si vous le prenez comme ça moi
perso je suis pour la politique encore
la politique toujours vous êtes très
proche de François Beyrou delfphine l'a
dit selon nos cofrères de Rue 89 il vous
appelle même 10 fois par jour vous avez
de la chance alors apparemment il vous
appelle pour un oui pour pour un N un
nom pardon c'est la mode en ce moment
avec tous les référendum ça tombe bien
alors certains disent que François
Baayou pour lui vous êtes un peu la
France profonde c'est quoi la France
profonde madame Gouro je suis pour lui
quelqu'un
qui a toujours été proche du terrain qui
a des racines dans le département où
elle vit et qui je crois par héritage
paysan à un certain sens
du discernement h h du bon sens on
dirait d'une autre manière et qui reste
bien les pieds sur terre et donc
François baayerou aime bien m'interroger
où on
discute qu'est-ce que tu as entendu par
exemple pour prendre un exemple récent
le brexit il m'a dit mais qu'est-ce que
tu as entendu sur le terrain qu'est-ce
que disent les gens euh il se trouve que
c'était la fête de l'école de ma petite
fille samedi comme beaucoup de monde et
voilà
et tous les gens m'ont parlé de ça tous
les gens m'ont parlé de ça ils me parlit
plus de la loi travail ils m'ont parlé
de la sortie de l'Angleterre et les gens
à la fois interrogatif tristes et en se
disant mais qu'est-ce qui va se passer
quel conséquence ça va avoir pour nous
encore dans une France déjà en
difficulté économique et sociale est-ce
que ça va pas être encore quelque chose
qui va se rajouter donc il consulte le
terrain en vous parlant il y a pas que
la politique dans la vie il y a aussi
vos chevaux bien s s un de vos chevals a
gagné le Prix du Président de la
République en 1981 si je suis bien
informé il paraît que c'est à partir de
ce moment-là que François Baayou a
commencé à croire en vous bref passons
vous êtes une grande lectrice de polar
il paraît des polars suédois norvégiens
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui vous plaît
dans les polars plus que dans dans autre
genre de de littérature euh j'aime bien
l'évasion j'aime bien aussi le mystère
et et la démarche
construite pour essayer de d'esseler la
vérité dans le et et l'énigme dans le
polar un peu comme en politique mais
peut-être peut-être mais c'est quelque
chose qui voilà j'aime bien les romans
d'une d'une manière générale mais j'aime
bien les polarards il paraît que vous
aimez beaucoup les livres de Camila
lacberg est-ce que vous avez lu le
dernier livre non il est sur ma table
mais je me le réserve vous savez
pourquoi parce que un vrai quand on est
amateur de Polard on prend son temps
pour le lire et je me le réserve pour
après le 22 juillet très bien je suis
triste parce que je vous l'avais acheté
en fait c'est un cadeau voulais vous
faire pour la fin de l'année je voulais
vous le dédicacer c'est pas grave je
vais le garder je vais le lire je
découvrirai Camilla lacberg dernière
question ma chronique est terminée
c'était drôle est-ce que vous avez aimé
je parle à la scénatrice Jacqueline
Gouro oui bien sûr enfin vous parlez à
la femme parce que moi j'ai pas de enfin
je fais pas de différence entre ce que
je suis dans la vie quotidienne ce que
je suis au Sénat voilà ou quand je suis
avec des personnalités politiques je
crois que c'est c'est ça qui est
important dans la vie c'est d'être
soi-même toujours d'accord bon ben c'est
gentil ça me fait plaisir on va demander
maintenant à la professeur d'histoire
Jaqueline Gouro est-ce que vous avez
aimé ma chronique regardons je ne vois
pas ce qu'il y a de
drôle voilà je crois que c'est clair
merci à vous et bonne fin de journée
merci Alex merci